wie viele aktive fälle haben wir im
moment in deutschland um die 8000 glaube
ich die ja irgendwo zwischen 18.000 was
glauben sie wie viele sind es
tatsächlich haben sie da eine idee davon
das ist ja wirklich schwer zu schätzen
also der wir haben das ja nur für die
gemeinde gangelt erst mal bestimmt oder
ministers wirklich auch wunderbar dass
in neustadt am rennsteig und in
kupferzell solche studien durchgeführt
werden das hat ja zwei aspekte einmal
für die dunkelziffer in diesem bereich
zu verstehen aber auch zu verstehen
wieso ein ausbruch ein bild von statten
geht wie es deutschlandweit die
dunkelziffer ist da das sind wirklich
schwere schätzungen die man anstellen
kann
und wir können das eigentlich aus
gangelt gar nicht hochrechnen aber das
besondere ist wir haben ja ein gangelt
eine unglaublichkeit rate bestimmt also
infection für carry trade eigentlich
also wie viele die infiziert sind daran
versterben
und wenn man sich die offiziellen zahlen
erst mal vorher angeguckt hat das ist
dann die casey teletrader gewesen
die belag zwischen zwei und 3,4 prozent
wir haben es runtergebrochen auf 0,37
prozent mit einem fehler bereich von
0,19 bis 0,45
da sollten sich jetzt auch nicht
abstreiten aber so wir sind ja mal unter
0,5 dabei gelandet und wird mehrere 123
mehr tote wird sich da kein nicht groß
verändern ja wenn man jetzt unsere
modelle und da sind wir leider falsch
interpretiert worden wenn man jetzt die
modelle die wird für deutschland haben
mit unseren faktor anpasst nicht mehr
von 2% sterblichkeitsrate sondern von
0,37 prozent ausgeht und diese modelle
an passt dann würde man damit rechnen zu
der zeit von rund zwei millionen
infizierten in deutschland also aber das
kann man nur bedingt machen natürlich
gangelt durch das super spreading
ereignis auch eine besondere situation
aber es kann uns einen hinweis geben
wie hoch die dunkelziffer sein könnte es
ist eine diskussionsgrundlage irgendwo
sie würden sagen im bereich von 2
millionen ja ja aber das ist wie gesagt
eine diskussionsgrundlage die man eben
auch ich will die nächsten studieren und
11 köln wären sie in relation setzen und
dann werden wir näher an ergebnis
schützen genau meine frage zur legalität
wenn ich darf zum nas ist also robert
koch das wollte auch institut hat ja
moment eine von vier prozent
und jetzt hat gangelt 0,3 prozent also
es hängt ja auch ganz offensichtlich
davon ab jedenfalls unter anderem
welches kollektiv das ist also wie das
durchschnittalter beispielsweise ist in
dem kollektiv wird in gangelt waren
wahrscheinlich viele die auch relativ
jung waren und in ganz deutschland sind
es halt vor allen dingen diejenigen die
auch etwas älter waren die vor erkrankt
waren also das ist eine andere
gruppierung wie sind da die
übertragbarkeit das ist das wo ich gerne
auch statistisch noch mehr informationen
in der öffentlichkeit hätte der einfache
antwort ist wir wissen es nicht dass das
problem aber bei den vier prozent für
ganz deutschland der vitalität die wir
vom robert-koch-institut ja annehmen
hängt das ja ganz stark davon ab wie
viele getestet wurden und wie viele
infos über wie viele infektionen man
eigentlich bescheid müssen also die
dunkelziffer die man nicht kennt
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass hier ein
gangelt ein anderes virus hatten haben
als im restlichen deutschland so dass
ich schon damit rechnen dass wir sehr
viel mehr infektionen haben die wir gar
nicht wahrnehmen und uns gibt darin
recht dass wir in gangelt jede fünfte
infektion überhaupt keine symptome hat
also die sich an nichts erinnern konnten
wenn man jetzt das super spreading
ereignis raus nimmt also die
karnevalssitzung die leute die richtig
viele angestellte diesem viele also wo
sich auch viele wirklich mit hoher
infektions doha virus angesteckt haben
da hat jeder dritte eine also wenn man
die rausnimmt hat dann jeder dritte eine
symptomatische erkrankung gehabt also
keine symptome verspürt was für mich
bedeutet dass wir viel mehr auch
übertragungen haben die wir gar nicht
wahrnehmen und man sieht es auch bei der
post verteilt
in hückelhoven im coesfeld also
aufschlag schlachthof ja das sind ja zu
facebook kunde gewesen
das waren ja nicht wirklich kranke
menschen da ist ja keiner von denen auf
der intensivstation gelandet sondern es
waren relativ milde symptome die die
menschen dort sind das ist super
spreading ist dass herr strikt eine der
wichtigsten erkenntnisse erkenntnisse
aus dieser studie das ist ja leider
alles auch durch die polemik die darum
entstanden ist ein bisschen
untergegangen
oder anders gefragt was ist die
wichtigste erkenntnis für sie in 1 23
aus dieser studie in heinsberg also ich
glaube einmal erstmal dass wir das virus
ein bisschen besser einschätzen können
und das mit den unter 0,5 wo dieses
sterblichkeit sie hatte zeigt mir
einfach es ist ein im vergleich zu
anderen tieren ist es ein
ernstzunehmendes virus aber wir können
sowieso sollten es auch nicht
überdramatisieren und wir müssen diese
gratwanderung auch weitergehen
das 2 1 das heißt es ist gefährlicher
oder harmloser für sie als vorher
gedacht
ich glaube diesen satz habe ich von
anfang an immer wieder gesagt also ich
hab das schon immer dass eigentlich von
meiner einschätzung her was was ja auch
aus china von den daten her belegt ist
dass fast 91 prozent komplett milde
symptomatiken haben oder mild bis
moderat der da lag ja schon die
einschätzung dabei dass es eigentlich
ein ein ernstzunehmendes virus ist aber
auch nicht zu überdramatisieren ist da
ja haben die ersten daten aus china da
schon suggeriert hin was uns angst
gemacht hat waren die bilder aus bergamo
und die bilder aus new york was du jörg
tauss auch aus johann zum teil also die
zusammen die die schiere wucht der
zahlen ist dann glaube ich schon ein
thema das war das dass wir immer wieder
diskutiert habe was ist die zweite
wichtigste erkenntnis wie viel das
stimmt bei uns in einer nicht erklärt
spätfolgen auch noch nicht geklärt genau
deswegen zweite wichtigste erkenntnis
für sie herrscht rege dass das doch eine
häufigere übertragung von also ohne
häufigen krankheitsverlauf ist die keine
symptome haben ich hatte ja selber
familien engel familien
angehörige die beide infiziert waren und
beide groß und geschmacksverlust hatten
und kratzigen hals aber ich habe mir
sorgen gemacht weil die zur risikogruppe
auch gehören dass eben auch
risikogruppen also mit vorerkrankungen
milde symptome haben können einen milden
verlauf haben können und eigentlich für
mich die spannendsten hinweis den wir
haben wie gesagt wir können es leider
nicht beweisen ist dass der zusammenhang
von der häufigkeit der symptome und der
infektionsrate mit so an dem super
stradinger band also der der
karnevalssitzung
das bedeutet dass die die an der
karnevalssitzung teilgenommen haben
nicht nur sich häufiger infiziert haben
als im späteren verlauf sondern was ja
ein hygiene aspekt dann ist sondern auch
sehr viel mehr und schwerere symptome
gehabt haben und das kennen wir von
anderen respiratorischen viren zum
beispiel der grippe da wurde das sogar
so ausprobiert das freiwilligen
grippeviren mit verschiedener dosis
gegeben wurde und je mehr grip plädieren
sie bekommen haben desto schwerer ist
die symptomatik was im umkehrschluss
bedeutet das wenn man die infektions
dosis reduzieren kann durch
hygienemaßnahmen abstand halten und
sonnenschutz das vielleicht sich
menschen infizieren aber dann eine milde
symptomatik haben und vielleicht sogar
auch ein verlauf haben oder symptom aber
was das ist interessant weil es würde ja
im nachhinein bedeuten dass wir einen
anderen lockdown möglicherweise hätten
machen sollen
in meinem nachhinein kann man die sachen
immer anders bewerten
wir haben gesehen dass und ich glaube
das zeigen jetzt auch die neuesten daten
vermehrt was wir schon in gangelt den
ersten hinweis haben dass es die
schlimmen ereignisse immer von solchen
super spreading ähnlich also wie
beispiel ich will genau das das kids
noch das berühmte fußballstadion
wie dann die in leer der die in der der
kirchenchor dann die
die alte scheune der letzte ausbruch
gebetshaus in frankfurt die trompete
also da gibt es sehr viele beispiele
organe wahl in heinsberg und das heißt
was war was war dort in diesem karneval
was war das sozusagen der punkt der
grund warum sich so viele leute so
schwer angesteckt haben haben die mit
mitgesungen haben die schlechte karten
tolle karnevalslieder gesungen oder
waren die zu dicht aufeinander was der
geschlossenen raum was war es also wir
wissen es noch nicht genau wir arbeiten
das gerade genau sehr akribisch ab aber
ein bereich der mich stutzig gemacht hat
ist allein 13 mal 19 quadratmeter raum
wo 425 leute gefeiert haben also sehr
viele menschen im engen raum beieinander
nur auf schlechte luft zirkulation
gewesen ist es haben sich also rund 40%
dort infiziert bei einer
karnevalssitzung was ja unheimlich viele
sind aber was die daten immer mehr
darauf suggerieren und wir kennen das
von anderen viren auch ist eben dieser
cluster effekt dass es und wenn sich das
bewahrheitet dass sich das virus so
verhält das ist eben also suggeriert
eben das zurzeit dass zehn prozent der
infizierten 80 der weitergabe ausmachen
also das ein ganz kleiner prozentsatz
von menschen das virus an andere
weitergeben
das bedeutet dass eigentlich diese grobe
absage der großveranstaltung was ganz am
anfang getroffen wurde
in der entscheidung dass das eigentlich
der wichtigste faktor war um das virus
einzudämmen
okay das ist schlimm als nachricht das
ist ja ja ja aber warum ist das schlimm
ich ahne was vielleicht stellen sie sich
vor was mit den theatern beispielsweise
passiert ja wir haben wir jetzt schon in
berlin
berliner ensemble weil sie zufällig sind
nur noch 30 prozent oder 40 prozent
besitzt überhaupt vorhanden konzerne
werden auch noch nicht mal aufgemacht im
moment wenn die wieder aufmachen dann
sind das ja wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe besonders hoch
die kuh bereiche dieser ist das was sie
meinen wenn sie sagen cluster effekt ja
nie ein also ich kann es ja natürlich
nicht sagen wie es im konzertsaal oder
im theater ist aber wir hatten ja auch
die schlimmen grippewellen in uns zuvor
und haben wir die konzerte nicht
abgesagt
und da geht dann geht es ganz genau am
ende um die verhältnismäßigkeit und am
ende um eine politische entscheidung wo
sehr viele faktoren rein spielen müssen
die die kein biologe bei einem waren
sich schon klar wenn ein biologen nehme
ich das leben bestimmen würde gold
gehört sich auch sehr sehr langweilig
werden wir keinen sex mehr würden nicht
mehr küssen
und weil das alles theoretisch ja viren
übertragen könnte und das ist ja
offensichtlich dass das langweilig das
heißt noch mal die frage das heißt
dieses diese super spreading momente
diese diese cluster von musik hat
gesprochen haben dass das ist etwas was
man mehr in den fokus nehmen muss das
heißt mit anderen worten das haben wir
ja gemacht bevor der richtige locker und
kam haben wir das ja schon gemacht das
heißt möglicherweise hätte das schon
gereicht waren das die entscheidenden
die nachhinein ist man immer schlauer
vielleicht uns ja zu verstehen ja
vielleicht in einem jahr werden wir
genau zu diesen punkt hin kommen also
wenn wir uns den erbfaktoren schauen das
ist ja auch nur bedingt aussagekräftig
sehen wir ja schon dass das das
vielleicht einen effekt haben konnte
auch auf auf das weitere
infektionsgeschehen zum er faktor gehört
bei infektionsepidemiologie immer auch
der faktor der cluster effekt dazu
meinen infektionsgeschehen zu beurteilen
und wenn wir jetzt mit ein bisschen
verspätung jetzt auch das noch mit den
fokus nehmen werden wir das eben auch
besser verstehen können was am ende die
richtigen maßnahmen sind aber das heißt
das heißt sie finden den weg den wir
jetzt gehen den finden sich richtig
heißt das übersetzt
ich schaue nicht gerne zurück und ich
schaue lieber vorwärts ja genau ich
denke dass das es dass wir gelernt haben
mit dem virus umzugehen
wir haben es gut eingedämmt wir haben
eine
wenige infektionszahlen auf die glaube
ich alle stolz sein können weil jeder
hat er ja mit beigetragen
wir werden in meinen augen wie wir jetzt
mit dem virus umgehen werden wir keine
zweite welle haben wir werden immer mal
wieder diese hotspots sehen und die
gehen dann von den einzelnen infektionen
aus von den einzelnen cluster festen aus
aber keine zweite welle
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass wir eine
zweite welle okay wäre dann eine letzte
ganz konkrete frage noch innerhalb von
familien ist auch immer so ein thema
kinder gehen in die kita oder ein
erwachsener ist krank wie groß ist die
ansteckungsgefahr untereinander ich
kenne ihre beispiele von menschen die
selber erkrankt sind die keinen einzigen
menschen der gesamten familie angesteckt
haben und andere die wiederum sehr viele
angesteckt haben
das haben wir uns in heinsberg auch
angeguckt deswegen hatten wir nach dem
velo protokoll und familien eingeladen
also oder haushalte und wenn zwei
personen zusammen gelebt haben wenn eine
war infiziert war beim anderen die
wahrscheinlichkeit bei 43% sich auch zu
infizieren okay so war sie fünfte vier
spieler etwas interessanter dass beim
vier-personen-haushalt das
runtergegangen ist auf 18 prozent
also dass sich eine weitere person
infiziert das sind häufig familien mit
kindern natürlich und wir können nicht
sagen wodurch das entsteht also ob das
jetzt weiß ein größeres haus ist die
menschen sind mehr auseinander gegangen
oder aber die kinder weniger infektiös
sind oder sich weniger infizieren das
können wir nicht sagen aber wir sehen
den zusammenhang mit größerem haushalt
dass wir weniger infektionen im haushalt
sind größere haushalt in der person
quadratmeterzahl und nur in personen
zwei songs also unser gibt doch gar
keins sind wie ich das so sagen es gibt
schon einen sinn in dem sinne dass wir
eben im haushalt selber kein cluster
effekt dass das anders bei roter oder
noroviren also solche typischen
schmierinfektionen wenn er einem
haushalt der infizierten sind alle
infiziert bei respiratorischen wir und
da kennen wir das von der grippe kennen
ja auch schon saß im übrigen sehen wir
auch so einen effekt dass es kein
spezielles clustern in der familie gibt
und das ist
er mit mir zusammen hängt dass sich
jemand also ein
das ist doch auch unlogisch wenn die
erneute zusammen sind sind sie doch in
der regel auch mehr gibt wir können wir
können es nicht erklären woran es liegt
da fehlen die studien zu aber wir können
da eben auch nur spekulieren aber wenn
einer im haushalt krankes da geht man
sich wahrscheinlich eher außen weg es
kann aber auch genau so sein dass die
kinder sich einfach weniger infiziert
haben